From beloved childhood favorites to the sex
icon of a generation, these actors may be
gone but won't soon be forgotten!
While technically the first live action portrayals
of the eponymous Mario brothers came in the
form of early '80s Atari commercials, "Captain"
Lou Albano's and Danny Wells' performance
as the daring duo is probably the most beloved.
They entertained millions of children beginning
in 1989 on "The Super Mario Bros. Super Show."
The show featured Albano and Wells playing
the two plumbers during live-action sequences
at their Brooklyn residence, often with a
celebrity guest, before switching over to
a cartoon episode of "Super Mario Bros." or
"The Legend of Zelda."
Albano and Wells also voiced Mario and Luigi
in the "Mario Bros." cartoon episodes. Captain
Lou was known for a prominent professional
wrestling career that started in 1953 and
ended in 1995, and he was inducted into the
WWE Hall of Fame a year later. Albano died
on October 14, 2009, from a heart attack at
the age of 76.
Danny Wells, who played Luigi, was known for
his TV guest appearances on the likes of "The
Jeffersons," "Happy Days," "Punky Brewster,"
"Chips," "The A-Team," "Sanford and Son,"
and "Starsky & Hutch." He also did voice acting
for "Heathcliff," "Batman: The Animated Series,"
"Bakugan," "Turbo Dogs," and more. He died
of undisclosed causes on November 28, 2013.
If you're one of the few people who made it
all the way through the "Jaws" franchise to
the fourth movie—1987's "Jaws: The Revenge"—you
may recognize Judith Barsi as the young granddaughter
of Police Chief Martin Brody.
Before that movie came out, Barsi had already
had small parts in well-known TV series including
"Cheers" and "Cagney & Lacey." Today, she
is best remembered for two Don Bluth feature
animations: She voiced Ducky, an excitable
young dinosaur, in 1988's "The Land Before
Time," and animal whisperer Anne-Marie in
"All Dogs Go to Heaven."
On July 25, 1988, four months before "The
Land Before Time" premiered, Judith, age 10,
and her mother Maria were shot dead by Judith's
abusive father, who then killed himself. According
to the Los Angeles Times, a neighbor said
that Maria had lived in fear for herself and
her daughter. She was trying to leave her
husband but feared he would find and kill them.
Both "The Land Before Time" and "All Dogs
Go to Heaven" came out after Judith and Maria's
deaths. Actor Heather Hogan voiced Ducky in
subsequent "Land Before Time" sequels.
Dana Hill originally wanted to be a track
star until type I diabetes ended her youthful
athletic dreams. Her father's career as a
commercial director helped her start in the
industry, and she booked a series of ads before
appearing on various television programs,
including "Mork & Mindy," "Fallen Angel,"
and "Magnum, P.I." She also voiced a variety
of animated characters for cartoons like "Rugrats,"
"Goof Troop," and "Darkwing Duck."
She's best recognized for playing Audrey Griswold
in "National Lampoon's European Vacation,"
replacing Dana Barron from "National Lampoon's
Vacation" a few years prior. Hill's life and
career were both cut short after suffering
a fatal stroke triggered by her diabetes on
July 15, 1996, at the age of 32.
A classically trained Shakespearian actor,
Helen McCrory made a name for herself on stage
and in a number of fan-favorite films and
television series.
For those who don't frequent the London theater,
McCrory was probably best known for playing
Narcissa Malfoy in the "Harry Potter" film
franchise. Other film credits include "Skyfall,"
"Hugo," "The Queen," and more. On television,
McCrory played Madame Kali in "Penny Dreadful,"
provided the voice for Stelmaria on "His Dark
Materials," and owned every scene she appeared
in as Polly Gray on "Peaky Blinders." She
passed away on April 16, 2021, at the age
of 52 from breast cancer while filming the
sixth season of "Peaky Blinders," and certain
storylines actually had to be rewritten due
to her untimely death.
Funnyman Louie Anderson had one of the most
iconic voices in the world of comedy. He was
an actor whom you could identify after just
hearing a few words from his mouth.
"'Well I just know it's a sound,' and he went,
'EHHHHH!' And the producer said, 'You mean…Louie Anderson?'"
"Yeah!"
Anderson's wit and quick-thinking delivery
made him a sought-after stand-up act—he
regularly appeared on late-night television
and celebrity game shows to help get the crowd rolling.
Anderson's television career was an interesting
one. Early on, he created a cartoon series
called "Life With Louie," based on his childhood
in the Midwest. Anderson voiced both the childhood
version of himself and his father in the series.
The show won a number of Daytime Emmy awards
in the mid-'90s. Anderson went on to appear
on many other shows in small, memorable roles
before becoming a critical darling again with
the FX series "Baskets." Anderson created
the show along with Zach Galifianakis, Louis
C.K., and Jonathan Krisel. He starred in the
series as Christine Baskets.
Anderson died on January 21, 2022, from lymphoma
at the age of 68. He had kept his diagnosis
private for over a decade, and passed away
just three days after releasing information
about his illness.
Robbie Coltrane was a total chameleon of an
actor. His characters were capable of displaying
warmth, silliness, and love, while also showcasing
fearsome strength and darkness. To be able
to do this once or twice is impressive, but
to do it again and again requires some serious
talent. It's no wonder Coltrane was honored
as an Officer of the Order of the British
Empire in 2006.
Coltrane jumped between comic and dramatic
roles with ease. His best-known characters
came from the world of film. He portrayed
Valentin Zukovsky, a former KGB officer and
frenemy of James Bond, in "Goldeneye" and
"The World Is Not Enough." His fame grew even
more when he was cast as gamekeeper Rubeus
Hagrid in the "Harry Potter" film franchise.
Playing one of the warmest characters in a
beloved franchise helped cement Coltrane's
acting legacy.
On the television side of things, Coltrane
regularly appeared in TV movies and miniseries
where he got to flex his acting muscles. He's
probably best known for the crime drama "Cracker,"
where he starred as Dr. Edward "Fitz" Fitzgerald.
Coltrane died on October 14, 2022, due to
ongoing health complications. He was 72 years old.
In the world of classic television, not many
shows stand above their peers like "Happy
Days." It ran for over a decade of television,
featuring 11 seasons and over 250 episodes,
and also helped launch the careers of notable
actors like Ron Howard, Henry Winkler, and
Scott Baio. One other actor who appeared in
every season of "Happy Days," and starred
in one of its spin-offs, was Erin Moran.
Moran played Joanie Cunningham, the younger
sister of Richie and Chuck, who eventually
starts dating Chachi. As the young couple
started gaining popularity on the show, a
spin-off series called "Joanie Loves Chachi"
was created. This new series was about a young
couple trying to start a musical act, and
the episodes featured performances from Baio
and Moran. "Joanie Loves Chachi" was not as
well-received as "Happy Days," and was canceled
during its second season. The characters popped
back up on "Happy Days" and actually got married
in the final episode.
Moran continued to find work after "Happy
Days," but never really returned to the spotlight.
She struggled with cancer later in life and
died in 2017 at the age of 56.
Even if you've never seen something she's
appeared in, you've probably seen pictures
of Raquel Welch. Welch was a major sex symbol
in the 1960s and beyond. She made her first
splash with the film "One Million Years B.C.,"
shooting to fame after appearing on the film's
poster clad only in an animal-skin bikini.
She only had a handful of lines in the film,
but that image was more than enough to make
her a household name.
Outside of that, Welch is probably best known
for roles in films like the 1973 version of
"The Three Musketeers," "Kansas City Bomber,"
"Bedazzled," and "Right to Die." She was a
regular guest on celebrity special`s and game
shows, and also had recurring roles on a handful
of short-lived series, like 2008's "Welcome
to the Captain" and 2017's "Date My Dad."
Raquel Welch died on February 15, 2023, at
the age of 82.
Whether you call him the Big Guy or Uncle
Phil, James Avery earned household name status
through his portrayal of Philip Banks on "The
Fresh Prince of Bel-Air." Prior to making
his mark on that long-running hit NBC sitcom,
the burly actor had plenty of small roles
throughout his TV career, although he was
particularly well known for his voice acting work.
"You may call me, "The Shredder."
Avery was the voice of Shredder on "Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles" and War Machine on "Iron
Man." He also did voices for a list of projects
that included "The Prince of Egypt," "Extreme
Ghostbusters," "Fist of the North Star," and
"Hulk Hogan's Rock 'n' Wrestling." A fatherly
presence despite his most famous character's
name, Avery saddened a generation of viewers
when he died from complications following
heart surgery on December 31, 2013, at the
age of 68.
Wendie Jo Sperber had small parts in two very
big movies. She was an uncredited dancer in
"Grease," one of the most famous musicals
of all time. And she played Marty McFly's
older sister Linda in "Back to the Future,"
reprising the role for "Back to the Future Part III."
Even before "Back to the Future," Sperber
was well known to some thanks to her part
in the sitcom "Bosom Buddies." The show starred
Tom Hanks as Kip and Peter Scolari as Henry,
two friends who have to pretend to be women
in order to get an apartment in a cheap women's-only
hotel. Sperber played Amy, their co-worker
and initially the only resident who knows
the men's secret.
In addition to regular movie roles, Sperber
also appeared in episodes of various hit TV
series including "Murphy Brown," "Will & Grace,"
"Home Improvement," and "JAG."
Sperber was diagnosed with breast cancer in
1997. Four years later, she founded weSPARK
Cancer Center, a nonprofit intended to support
other patients and their families. She died
on November 29, 2005, at the age of 47.
When it came to the characters on "Saved by
the Bell," the odd man out was often Sam Powers,
better known as Screech. The "Saved by the
Bell" bunch boasted a nice collection of stereotyped
characters, and Screech was the dork. Though
Screech typically appeared as a side character,
often aiding the schemes of Zack and Slater,
actor Dustin Diamond was still able to showcase
his comedic talents. That helped him carve
out a solid identity for a character that
could have easily been a throwaway member
of the central cast.
Like his character, however, Diamond was kind
of the odd man out of the main cast. After
the show ended, Diamond struggled to land
substantial roles, and often found himself
at the center of bizarre controversies. A
sex tape was leaked in 2006 — one that Diamond
later admitted he himself released, with a
body double replacing him in most of the scenes.
Diamond would also release a behind-the-scenes
tell-all book called "Behind the Bell," in
which he aired out all the dirty laundry on
his "Saved by the Bell" costars. He would
later admit that a ghostwriter made up almost
everything in the book.
Diamond passed away from lung cancer in 2021.
He was 44 years old.
Earl Hindman had a relatively low-profile
show business career, but he stayed consistently
busy for decades, appearing in movies like
"The Taking of Pelham One Two Three." Throughout
the '70s and '80s, he had his most consistent
visibility in the part of Bob Reid, a character
he played in more than 450 episodes of the
long-running ABC daytime drama "Ryan's Hope."
It was a steady gig whose reliability and
dramatic potential would be the envy of most working actors.
It was another supporting role on a long-running
series, however, that ultimately earned Hindman
his greatest notoriety.
"Howdy, neighbor!"
Most '90s kids will remember him as Wilson,
the mysterious-but-friendly neighbor of Tim
"The Toolman" Taylor on the hit sitcom "Home
Improvement." Hindman died on December 29,
2003, at the age of 61 due to lung cancer,
leaving a generation with fond memories of
that lovable neighbor behind the fence who
always had the best advice and most interesting hobbies.
"Hey, Wilson what are you doing?"
"Well, hi-ho Taylor teen! I am sculpting a
shrine out of yack butter."
One of "The Original Kings of Comedy" next
to Cedric the Entertainer, D. L. Hughley,
and Steve Harvey, Bernie Mac built his hugely
successful career through a stand-up routine
heavily influenced by Richard Pryor. That
in and of itself isn't unusual but Mac used
that cornerstone to build a presence and style
that was uniquely his own.
"I never watched what somebody else does.
It does not matter. Bernie Mac gotta do his thing."
That hard work paid off in Hollywood with
a series of high-profile roles. Many might
recognize Mac as Ice Cube's neighbor, Pastor
Clever, in the movie "Friday." He'd go on
to star in "Charlie's Angels: Full Throttle,"
"Ocean's Eleven," "Transformers," and more,
and also headlined a sitcom, loosely based
on his own experiences, called 'The Bernie
Mac Show'. During the last years of his life,
Mac suffered from Sarcoidosis, which heavily
affected his lungs, and he succumbed to pneumonia
complications on August 9, 2008, at the age of 50.
Harold Ramis was 69 when he passed away from
an autoimmune disease in 2014, which in and
of itself might have come as a surprise to
many of the film fans who watched him in '80s
classics like "Stripes," "National Lampoon's
Vacation," and "Ghostbusters." A talented
director and screenwriter as well as a frequent
fixture in some of the biggest comedy hits
of the decade, Ramis' behind-the-scenes talents
helped bring us "Groundhog Day" and "Caddyshack,"
among many others; in fact, he jumped back
and forth between either side of the cameras
throughout his career, co-writing both of
the "Ghostbusters" movies as well as "Stripes."
Although few fans knew he was ill, Ramis struggled
with the side effects of his infection for
years—he had to learn how to walk all over
again after contracting autoimmune inflammatory
vasculitis in 2010, and suffered a relapse
the following year. His final onscreen appearance
came in the 2009 comedy Year One.
A veteran of stage and screen who amassed
a distinguished career spanning decades, Richard
Harris notched arguably his highest-profile
role late in his career, courtesy of the blockbuster
"Harry Potter" film franchise. In two of his
final screen appearances, Harris played Potter's
beloved headmaster Albus Dumbledore in the
first two installments of the blockbuster
film franchise, "The Sorcerer's Stone" and
"The Chamber of Secrets."
Although he'll always be Dumbledore to generations
of Potter-loving fans, outside of Hogwarts,
Harris compiled multiple careers' worth of
impressive credits and honors. He was an accomplished
singer, actor, director, writer, producer,
and songwriter who won Grammy and Golden Globe
awards for his work on 15 different albums
and more than 70 films, including "Camelot,"
"The Guns of Navarone," "Gulliver's Travels,"
"Patriot Games," "Unforgiven," "Gladiator,"
and "The Count of Monte Cristo." After being
diagnosed with Hodgkin's disease, Harris died
on October 25, 2002 at the age of 72.
Best known for playing the young Carol Anne
from the movie "Poltergeist," Heather O'Rourke
skyrocketed to instant fame as the sweet young
girl that terrified audiences after being
sucked into the television set. In fact, she
may have played the part a little too well:
although O'Rourke racked up an impressive
list of credits after her breakthrough performance
as Carol Anne, she remained tied to the franchise
in the public's mind, and she was one of a
very small number of original cast members
that remained with the movie series until
its conclusion with 1988's "Poltergeist III."
If you've seen the final movie, you may notice
that Heather's cheeks appear very puffy—and
although audiences didn't know it at the time,
it was a reaction to the medication she was
taking for Crohn's disease, with which she
was misdiagnosed. Tragedy struck on February
1, 1988, when Heather suffered from cardiac
arrest while undergoing a surgery for a bowel
obstruction at the tender age of 12.
Thuy Trang was best known for her work as
the original Yellow Ranger on "Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers," but unlike a lot of actors
who start out in genre TV, she seemed in no
danger of being typecast; in fact, she was
developing what seemed like a potentially
promising career after leaving the show. Trang
jumped right into feature work, landing roles
in a pair of movies released in 1996: the
dark drama "The Crow: City of Angels" and
the Leslie Neilsen comedy "Spy Hard."
Clearly, Trang had enough chops to tackle
work from a variety of genres, but sadly,
she never had a chance to fulfill that potential—she
was killed in a car accident at the age of
27 in 2001, after the driver lost control
of the vehicle and it plunged over a guardrail
on California's Interstate 5. Emergency medical
personnel tried getting Trang to the hospital,
but she died in transit, the result of massive
internal injuries.
One of Hollywood's all-time ultimate 'That
Guy' actors, Taylor Negron compiled a truly
impressive list of classic screen credits
without ever becoming a household name. Although
he tended to be on screen for no more than
a few moments at a time, Negron's deadpan
delivery made him a fan favorite among film
aficionados of the '80s—and a standout in
pictures like "Fast Times at Ridgemont High"
and "Better Off Dead".
Later in his career, Negron made memorable
appearances on hit TV shows like "Seinfeld"
and "Friends", but as much fun as he could
be onscreen, he was even more interesting
behind the scenes. In addition to acting,
Negron was an acclaimed writer whose work
included published collections of short stories,
as well as a trained painter whose work was
shown in multiple galleries. He was only 57
when he died in early 2015, after a battle
with liver cancer.
After making a name for himself as a professional
wrestler, "Rowdy" Roddy Piper branched out
onto the big screen, most notably through
his starring role in the 1988 cult classic
"They Live". Leading that cult John Carpenter
classic, Piper waged war against a covert
alien invasion and coined an unforgettable
catchphrase.
"I have come here to chew bubble gum and kick
ass, and I'm all out of bubble gum."
Piper's bone-crunching work in that film helped
set the tone for a busy Hollywood career full
of B-movie roles and small-but-unforgettable
appearances on television shows like "It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia." On the screen
as well as in the ring, Piper gave every performance
his all, frequently elevating otherwise forgettable
material and consistently serving as the most
memorable component of whatever project he
was appearing in. He died in his sleep in
2015 after suffering a pulmonary embolism
that triggered a heart attack.
Critically maligned and pretty much ignored
at the box office, "Rocky V" is indisputably
the least loved film of Sylvester Stallone's
long-running boxing franchise. Take a careful
look under its cheesier elements, however,
and you can see the outline of a truly affecting
story about a former heavyweight champ going
broke, losing his ability to box, and nearly
losing his relationship with his son.
To help tell the story, Stallone brought in
his own 14-year-old son, Sage, to play the
part of Robert "Rocky Jr." Balboa in the film,
and the young Stallone's time on the set clearly
made a positive impression: after college,
Sage continued working in the industry in
small, low-key projects, carving out a career
in his own right apart from his blockbuster-leading
father. Unfortunately, Sage died on July 13,
2012, at the young age of 36 due to a heart
attack brought on by coronary artery disease.
Long before he founded an ill-fated amusement
park using the secrets of dino DNA, Richard
Attenborough was already an accomplished and
award-winning actor. Attenborough starred
alongside Steve McQueen in "The Great Escape",
released in the midst of a busy period that
included some of his most widely seen work.
He also won two consecutive Golden Globe Awards
in 1967 and 1968 for co-starring in "The Sand
Pebbles" and "Doctor Dolittle".
Needless to say, Attenborough's career contains
no shortage of highlights, and his work will
no doubt be familiar to classic film fans.
Younger filmgoers, however, have their own
Attenborough memories thanks to his appearance
as John Hammond, whose ambitions led to the
creation of Jurassic Park. That blockbuster
made him famous to a whole new generation,
but it's just one short chapter in a life
of many great cinematic achievements that
ended on August 24, 2014 at the age of 90.
"Whatchoo talkin' 'bout Willis?"
Kids of the '70s and '80s and honestly anyone
who enjoys the classic sitcoms of the era
will immediately recognize the immortal catchphrase
Gary Coleman coined as an adorable kid on
the long-running hit sitcom "Diff'rent Strokes."
Coleman's diminutive stature helped him continue
to play younger characters throughout much
of his career, and at the peak of his fame,
he landed a series of film and television
roles. Unfortunately, his youthful looks and
peak height of 4 feet 8 inches were side effects
of an autoimmune kidney disease, combined
with the medications he took throughout his
life to fight the condition. Work in Hollywood
became harder to come by after "Strokes" left
the airwaves, and behind the scenes, he underwent
frequent dialysis treatments, and was forced
to undergo two kidney transplants. After a
fall at his home, Coleman died on May 28,
2010 of an epidural hematoma at the age of
42.
Exactly where you remember esteemed actor
Edward Herrmann from depends on whether you
favor musicals, vampire movies, medical TV
shows, or fast-talking mother-daughter family dramas.
Herrmann is probably best recognized today
for his role as pompous but warm-hearted patriarch
Richard Gilmore in the series "Gilmore Girls."
Richard's dry sense of humor and quiet authority
contrasted with the quick wit and constant
banter that flew between his daughter Lorelai,
his granddaughter Rory and his wife Emily,
who was played by Kelly Bishop.
Offscreen, Herrmann and Bishop, both classically
trained and meticulous about their craft,
were especially close. Herrmann's wife Star,
whom he married in 1994, would joke that Bishop
was his other wife. In Herrmann's final moments,
his family invited Bishop to say goodbye with them.
Before his longest-running role in "Gilmore
Girls," Herrmann worked regularly on TV and
in movies. He was nominated for an Emmy for
playing a priest in the medical drama "St.
Elsewhere," and won one for the legal series
"The Practice." He played Franklin D. Roosevelt
in the 1982 adaptation of "Annie" — having
previously played the President for a miniseries
and TV movie in the late '70s. And in 1987,
he played a stepfather from literal Hell in
the vampire movie "The Lost Boys."
Herrmann died of brain cancer, at age 71 on
December 21, 2014. In the Netflix revival
of "Gilmore Girls," it was revealed that Richard
had also died, sparking big changes for Emily in particular.
Deezer D was one of the foundational actors
on hit medical drama "ER." Born Dearon Thompson,
he played nurse Malik McGrath for the show's
entire 15-year run, appearing in 188 episodes.
As often happens in real hospitals as well
as fictional ones, "ER" typically focused
on its physicians and surgeons, not the nurses.
But Thompson was one of just a handful of
actors who appeared in every season, and his
episode count makes him the fifth most prolific
member of the large cast.
Outside of "ER," Thompson had a few small
parts in movies including the cult classic
comedy "Romy and Michele's High School Reunion"
and appeared in Vanilla Ice's video for "Cool
as Ice." He played one of the members of a
fictional rap group in the mockumentary movie
"CB4" in 1993, and also rapped for real. He
released multiple records, including the full-length
album "Delayed, But Not Denied" in 2008, and
continued making songs until his death. His
final track, "History Can't Be Stopped," was
released posthumously.
Thompson started having heart issues around
2008, telling RadarOnline the following year
that he had been suffering from recurrent
pneumonia and heart failure. It was discovered
that he had a leaking valve and expanded aorta,
which was addressed with surgery in 2009.
According to Deadline, he went on to have
more operations on his heart over the next
10 years or so. Thompson died on January 7,
2021, at the age of 55, of a suspected heart attack.
Kathryn Joosten was in her 50s when she started
working consistently in notoriously youth-centric
Hollywood in the mid 1990s. She'd started
acting in 1980, after realizing she was missing
out on following her dreams.
Despite her late start, Joosten built a career
playing one-off but always memorable characters
in hit TV series. Her credits include "ER,"
"3rd Rock From the Sun," "Seinfeld,'' "Roseanne,"
"The Nanny," "Frasier," "Buffy the Vampire
Slayer," and "The X Files," to name just a
few. Later she would add the likes of "Will
& Grace" and "Grey's Anatomy" to that list.
In short, name a hit show of the '90s and
'00s, and Joosten probably appeared in it.
Her most memorable guest appearance was as
a woman who refused treatment for kidney failure
in Season 1 of "Scrubs." The episode, "My
Old Lady," consistently ranks as a fan favorite,
thanks in no small part to Joosten's performance.
"Unfortunately we don't really have a choice."
"Actually I do have a choice."
"Certain things you never expect to come out
of a person's mouth."
"I think I'm ready to die."
In addition to those guest roles, Joosten
landed regular parts in two major series.
She played the steely secretary to Martin
Sheen's President Bartlet in two seasons of
"The West Wing," combining her talents for
fast-paced drama and comedy, and nosy but
occasionally helpful neighbor Karen McCluskey
in "Desperate Housewives."
Joosten was first treated for lung cancer
in 2001, the year "My Old Lady" aired. She
was undergoing treatment while making the
final season of "Desperate Housewives," which
was written into her character's arc. McCluskey
died in the series finale. Joosten died two
weeks after that episode aired, on June 2,
2012, at the age of 72.
Hugh Dane's resume reads like a list of the
top sitcoms of the '90s and early '00s. He
played two different characters in "The Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air," appeared in an episode
of "Martin," and multiple episodes of "Roc."
He had small parts in "Friends," "Sister,
Sister," "Everybody Hates Chris," and "New
Girl." On the drama side, he played a judge
in an episode of "The West Wing." He also
appeared briefly in the comedy movies "Little
Fockers" and "Bridesmaids."
However, Dane will most likely be remembered
and missed for his role as Hank, the permanently
unimpressed security guard in "The Office."
He appeared in 22 episodes of NBC's hit mockumentary
about the inner workings and ridiculous shenanigans
in a Scranton, Pennsylvania paper company.
Dane died at the age of 75 on May 16, 2018.
After his death, his "The Office" co-star
Rainn Wilson described him as "one of the
greats. So kind, funny, talented." On January
1, 2021, NBC's streaming platform Peacock
tweeted a video of a cold open that never
aired, dedicated to Dane. It showed one of
Jim's most elaborate pranks on nemesis Dwight,
featuring Dane as Morpheus from "The Matrix."
"If the blue pill's not safe to swallow, someone
should tell us now!"
Kenny Baker originated one of the most beloved
characters in one of the most popular movie
franchises of all time — but you wouldn't
recognize him from that role out of costume.
Baker is most famous for playing R2-D2, the
brave and mischievous "Star Wars" droid. He
was a dwarf, but it wasn't just Baker's height
that made him perfect for the role. According
to his New York Times obituary, he was the
only person small enough to fit into the costume
who was also strong enough to move it.
It helped that Baker had been in entertainment
for years: He sang, danced, played instruments,
clowned, and ice skated in various touring
companies. As he told the Guardian -
"There are certain closeup movements only
I can do convincingly. It's all about giving
R2 a personality, and CGI can never really
do that."
In addition to R2, Baker played an Ewok in
"Return of the Jedi," alongside his wife and
fellow actor Eileen. But the furry, violent
inhabitants of the jungle planet Endor were
less fun to play than to watch, thanks to
the stuffy costumes. It wasn't just that they
were hot: The heads were impossible to see
out of when they steamed up.
The last time Baker played R2 was for "Revenge
of the Sith," although he served as a consultant
on "The Force Awakens." He also appeared in
many other movies and series, including "Flash
Gordon," "Time Bandits" and "Amadeus." He
died at the age of 81 on August 13, 2016.
If you're a millennial who grew up wishing
you could have an identical twin to swap lives
with, you probably remember Natasha Richardson
best for her role as the extremely cool fashion
designer mom in the Lindsay Lohan-led remake
of "The Parent Trap."
That was Richardson's most prominent screen
role, but she had a prestigious stage career.
It started with a touring version of "The
Seagull" which ended in London's West End,
with Richardson appearing opposite her mother,
renowned British actor Vanessa Redgrave.
TV fans may know Vanessa best for her role
as Dr. Erica Noughton in "Nip/Tuck," opposite
her other daughter and Natasha's sister, Joely
Richardson. Joely should also be known to
fans from "The Parent Trap" era as Anita in
the 1996 live-action adaptation of "101 Dalmatians."
As you've probably noted, Natasha was part
of an acting dynasty. Her grandfather Sir
Michael Redgrave, Vanessa's father, was famous
for tragedies. Natasha's aunt, Lynn Redgrave,
Vanessa's sister, was an Oscar-nominated theater
superstar. To round out the family, Lynn and
Vanessa's brother, Corin Redgrave, was a stage
actor and playwright.
Natasha met actor Liam Neeson when they starred
opposite each other in a Broadway production
of "Anna Christie." She was nominated for
a Tony for the role, and the two later married
and had two sons together.
Natasha died suddenly of head injuries sustained
during a skiing trip on March 18, 2009. She was 45.
In a show that made superstars out of its
six main cast members, James Michael Tyler
managed to hold his own as one of the most
memorable side characters.
He played coffee shop manager Gunther in "Friends"
for all 10 seasons, appearing in 150 episodes
total, although he didn't have a line for
his first 33 appearances. Tyler originally
landed the role because he knew how to work
the fancy espresso machine on the Central Perk set.
Not one to take himself overly seriously,
after "Friends," he played himself in the
satire "Episodes," which saw that version
of Tyler experiencing a slightly awkward reunion
with Matt LeBlanc, who played Joey on "Friends,"
also playing himself.
Tyler loved the experience of being in "Friends,"
although there was one drawback. As he told
Digital Spy, he was cast with very distinctive
bleached blonde hair, which added to his character's
mystique. But it was originally the result
of an experiment he let one of his friends
perform, which turned into weekly bleach jobs
for 10 years.
Tyler was diagnosed with prostate cancer in
2018, which he didn't make public until June
2021. That month, he announced in an interview
with NBC that the cancer had reached stage
four, meaning it had spread to other parts
of his body. He died just a few months later,
on October 24, 2021.
A veteran stage, film, and television actor,
Richard Griffiths is known by the masses for
his portrayal of Harry Potter's uncle, Vernon
Dursley. While Dursley was for the most part
always cruel to the young wizard, he was still
a part of Harry's family—and he ultimately
helped prove that the Boy Who Lived had a
golden heart because he still cared for the
uncle who treated him poorly.
Outside of the "Harry Potter" series, Griffiths
won a slew of awards over the course of a
busy career, earning particular acclaim for
his portrayal of English teacher Douglas Hector
in a play called "The History Boys." He also
starred in a variety of projects, including
"Superman II," "Gandhi," "Sleepy Hollow,"
"King Ralph," "Hugo," "Pirates of the Caribbean:
On Stranger Tides," and "The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy." Griffiths passed away
at 65 on March 28, 2013 due to complications
shortly after having heart surgery.
Brad Renfro skyrocketed to fame at age 11
through his acclaimed work in Joel Schumacher's
adaptation of author John Grisham's book "The
Client." High profile roles quickly followed,
and Renfro made appearances in "Sleepers"
opposite Brad Pitt, "The Informers" starring
Kim Basinger, and "Ghost World" alongside
Scarlett Johansson.
Yet as his star continued to rise on screen,
Renfro faced a darker path behind the scenes,
one that would ultimately see him fulfilling
the sad destiny of many child actors, plunging
into a life of illegal drug use and trouble
with the law. After attempting to buy drugs
from an undercover L.A. police officer, Renfro
pleaded no contest to attempted possession
of heroin and spent ten days in jail. On January
15, 2008, at 25 years old, Renfro's turbulent
story reached a tragic end when he was found
dead of an accidental heroin and morphine
overdose in his apartment in Los Angeles.
Dana Plato played Kimberly Drummond in the
long-running hit television series Diff'rent
Strokes. Cast alongside fellow child stars
Gary Coleman and Todd Bridges, she was catapulted
to instant stardom. To cope with the mounting
pressures of fame, Plato often indulged in
cocaine and marijuana off the set—yet it
wasn't until she became pregnant that the
network released her from her contract, helping
trigger a downward spiral of drugs and alcohol
that included work in adult films and a spread
in Playboy magazine.
She later moved to Las Vegas, where, desperate
for cash, she robbed a store for less than
$200 and was bonded out of jail by Vegas entertainer
Wayne Newton. She died at the age of 35 on
May 8, 1999, in her RV in Oklahoma after taking
a fatal dose of lortab and valium.
Best known for her work starring as Mel Gibson's
daughter in the blockbuster "The Patriot,"
Skye McCole Bartusiak was a child actress
with a promising future. She made her film
debut in "The Cider House Rules" in 1999 and
starred with Michael Douglas and Brittany
Murphy in "Don't Say a Word" in 2001. She
also appeared in the film "Kill your Darlings"
with "True Blood" star Alexander Skarsgard
in 2006.
Unfortunately, Bartusiak's life behind the
scenes wasn't as glamorous as fans might have
assumed—and included some dangerous drug
habits that would end up contributing to her
having an accidental overdose in 2014. According
to Bartusiak's mother, the young star had
also been suffering from epileptic seizures
prior to her passing, which led the family
to initially believe she'd choked to death
before the coroner's ruling made the tragic
truth clear.
Before getting his big break, Michael K. Williams
was consistently cast as one-dimensional criminals.
He was a young Black man in a white industry
that didn't know how to tell diverse stories
about people who looked like him. Also, he
had a distinctive facial scar from the time
someone attacked him with a razor–something
else Hollywood didn't know what to do with.
Williams' big break came courtesy of "The
Wire" character Omar Little, an armed robber
who targets drug dealers, and the most feared
man in a territory ruled by violence. But
Little wasn't a carbon copy of those previous
characters. For one thing, he was openly gay,
in a homophobic society that mocked gay men
as weak. For another, he was known to give
some of his ill-gotten gains to people in
his much-in-need community.
After playing Omar, Williams landed roles
in several prestigious series, including crime
drama "The Night Of," "When We Rise," about
the gay civil rights movement, and a recurring
part as a racketeer in Prohibition drama "Boardwalk
Empire." He even got to show off his comedy
skills in "Community." In 2019, he appeared
in Ava DuVernay's "When They See Us," as the
father of one of the wrongly accused Central
Park Five. In 2021, he was nominated for his
fifth Emmy for the HBO series "Lovecraft County."
Williams died at the age of 54 on September
6, 2021, of what was later confirmed as a drug overdose.
The Famous Jett Jackson, Lee Thompson Young's
star vehicle, was a very popular show on The
Disney Channel for some time. Friday Night
Lights, Akeelah and the Bee, and The Hills
Have Eyes II are some of the few films on
Young's impressive resume. But while working
as a series regular on Rizzoli and Isles,
he was diagnosed with Bipolar Disorder. Sadly,
on August 19, 2013, his life came to a tragic
end after he committed suicide with a self-inflicted
gunshot wound.
Dominique Dunne was born into a life of privilege
in Santa Monica to a ranching heiress and
TV writer and producer Dominick Dunne. Dominique
made appearances in the TV shows Chips, Fame,
and The Quest. But the same year Poltergeist
was released, her deranged ex-boyfriend, John
Thomas Sweeney, murdered her in her own driveway
in West Hollywood on November 4, 1982.
With a resume as long as your arm, Jonathan
Brandis showed up in Who's the Boss?, Blossom,
L.A. Law, Full House, The Wonder Years, and
Murder, She Wrote, among tons of others. As
a child and teenage star for many years, it
seemed like he had no shortage of work. He
was 16 when he made Ladybugs, and 17 when
he was cast as a teen genius in Steven Spielberg's
SeaQuest 2032. When SeaQuest was canceled
in 1996, however, the once-plentiful casting
offers dried up. Depression soon plagued the
young star. He died after sustaining injuries
from an attempted suicide via hanging at the
age of 27 in Danbury, Connecticut.
Kelly made audiences laugh as part of the
ensemble cast of That '70s Show, but her real
life wasn't funny at all. After a lengthy
battle with drug and alcohol addiction that
ultimately caused her to lose her job on the
show, Kelly checked into rehab in August 2013,
only to pass away in her sleep due to complications
from an accidental overdose. She was only 43.
Duncan's towering physique made him a natural
for "big guy" roles, but he really had dramatic
chops—and unlike a lot of actors booked
for that type of part, he got a chance to
show them. His too-brief filmography includes
memorable supporting turns in Armageddon and
Daredevil, as well as a beautifully sensitive
starring performance in the big-screen adaptation
of Stephen King's The Green Mile. Duncan should
have had a much longer career, but he was
felled by a heart attack in 2012 at the age
of 54.